more bubbly than your favorite champagne
smoother than your camembert it's the
wonder woman of cheese and owner of
valley cheese and wine diana breyer
thanks for having me again good to have
you merry christmas merry christmas to
you and you're going to educate us today
on
champagne because the celebrations are
underway and what do you drink to
celebrate champagne and i there's such
an interesting fact about champagne that
most people may know but it's only
called champagne if it's from the
champagne region right so otherwise it's
a sparkling wine now what do we have we
have three different tiers here today
what's going on three tiers of bubbly
three cheers for bubbly with like three
tiers of bubbly because we're a little
catchy around here
but we actually wanted to highlight
something that doesn't even fall into
the champagne category per se okay so
this one is actually going to be a
cremonte de loire so cremont actually
means that it is a method champagnois so
what that means is that it's produced in
the traditional champagne like
production style it just doesn't come
from that region and possibly uses a
different type of grape so this one is
100 chenin blanc which is what you have
in your glass okay and is a cremanta
loire so it's a traditional champagne
style but and it's going to taste and
feel like a champagne but it retails for
under twenty dollars under twenty
dollars that's nice you don't have to
spend a lot of nice bright high acid
there a little bit of like dryness a
little bit of like green apple in there
really easy to drink it's so funny you
said apple that's like the first thing i
tasted that is delicious wow and then
this is good champagne is good with
anything really in my opinion but i
definitely brought some brie and some
caviar because if you are celebrating
this year there's no better pairing for
champagne than a double or a triple
cream brie and nothing better to go with
it than some caviar okay let's move to
the second tier here now this is a true
champagne this is a true champagne this
is what we call a grower producer okay
which means that the grapes are actually
on site where they produce the champagne
so the vineyard is not far from the
champagne production house this is an
entirely female lead and owned a
champagne house in that region
and it's really beautiful it's got a
nice high acidity again you'll get a
little bit of those green apple notes
but you'll also get some toasty brioche
in there now what does a bottle like
this retail for this is about fifty
dollars give or take 54.99 okay
hey man it's a celebration
like if you're wanting to go up a notch
from your under 20 and just take it into
the 50 zone this is a perfect champagne
for that this is actually a staff
favorite at the shop okay now let's say
we are just rolling large and we've got
the cash to spend yes ma'am we want to
go to this one what is this so this is
actually one of only 25 walled champagne
vineyards in the champaign region so the
vines actually are on walls in our
walden
and the reason why it seemed clo to
monet is actually wall of money because
they found old roman coins in this
vineyard um so they actually this is a
truly historic champagne and it is just
gonna be so warming and so celebratory
and again have those toasty nutty
brioche notes that are just beautiful
now what does something like this go for
this one is about 209 209 still not the
highest dollar that you can do with
champagne but this is going to be if
you're trying to have a little clout
with your party you best be celebrating
you better yeah i think you better be
bringing some some money champagne if
people want to get their champagne and
so much more where do they go find you
you're going to come find me at valley
cheese and wine in henderson on vale
verde but like it's on horizon ridge
between valley verde and stephanie but
yeah we are happy to have you happy to
have anyone anytime we are a family
owned business and we just love having
everybody be part of our family
especially during this holiday season
and she knows the business the wonder
woman of cheese anna thank you so much